Hey, this is Brian from Fullstack Egg.
I'm going to show you how to install Papeless NGX and Pap
eless Egg to a digital ocean droplet.
And by the end of this video, you'll have a working
document archive.
You can search using AI.
I'm going to start on paperless.fullstack.egg and I'm going
to use the button to deploy to
digital ocean.
You don't have to use our button, you can just create a dro
plet manually.
The button just sets a couple of defaults for you.
So I'm going to scroll past the region and you can see that
Ubuntu is selected for us
and we have a basic droplet with a regular CPU and 4GB of
memory.
And for authentication, I'm going to use my SSH key that I
have already added to digital
ocean and this will allow me to securely log into the
server without typing a password
in every time.
You can click add SSH key and digital ocean has
instructions for how to generate the
SSH key on your computer and get the key added to digital
ocean.
And finally, we need to give our droplet a name, I'm going
to call my paperless video.
So now we have a droplet that is going to cost us $24 a
month and we'll go ahead and
hit create.
This will take a minute to spin up, so I'll fast forward.
And here it is ready and we have our IP address.
So to connect to our new server, we will copy the IP
address and open up a terminal.
And we will type SSH root at and paste the IP address.
I'll hit return and if it asks about a fingerprint, I'll
type yes.
And now we're logged into our server.
And now we get to do the fun part.
We're going to go to paperless.fullstack.egg and copy the
install script.
And we'll go back to our terminal where we're logged into
our server.
And we'll paste the script and run it.
The script is going to ask us a few questions.
So the install directory, the default is fine.
We'll choose our username and password to log into paper
less.
And if you have a domain name, you're going to point that
your digital ocean droplet,
you can enter it here.
Otherwise you can skip it and just access it by the IP
address.
So now the script is pulling down all the pieces and
starting everything up.
This will take a few minutes and I'll just skip ahead here.
And we're done.
The script tells us everything we need.
Here's the URL to access paperless.
And here are the details we'll need later to connect to
cloud.
And I'll just save these somewhere.
And let me make sure it's working.
I'm going to open my browser, go to my server's IP address.
And I'll log in with the username and password I just set
up.
And there it is, paperless is running.
And to get started, I can just drag and drop a PDF right
into the browser.
And paperless is going to process it, read the text and add
it to my archive.
And our search add-on will automatically pick it up as well
.
Be sure to check out our video about what we added to paper
less.
Our paperless egg add-on.
And in that video, we show you how to connect paperless to
cloud and make queries using
just plain English.
And that's the whole thing.
Now you've got a searchable document archive that you can
access from anywhere.
And you're in full control of your own data.
So I've shown you how easy this is to get set up on digital
ocean, but you might not
want to pay $24 a month for this.
So in another video, I'm going to show you how to install
this on a Raspberry Pi.
The Raspberry Pi you'll need will cost you around $200.
But it'll save you almost $300 a year.
So go ahead and check that video out as well.
And thanks for watching.